what's a food pocket man welcome
everybody back to the what's up fool
pocket about do go toys right here yeah
man Lisa Esparza our guest Jamie Kennedy
man what's up what I haven't seen this
[ __ ] gato butt naked in there bro I was
get naked before Bobby how are you I'm
trying to think how long have I known
you a long time bro
like I would mention you you were like
what I was promoting my extra special
the recipe would you started off with
man I started off at this ding yes
please call the natural punch Yahweh I
father daily weekly I said open mic and
I was just like foxy bear record yea I
saw the Mooney twig there bro
Ricki Tarr of big-ass by Ricky hmm so
though we're talking about the back of
the day I thought when I first saw you
yeah I'll dude I'm thinking like but I
remember I told or that you told me that
whatever that I was the Comedy Store
yeah you were hanging out and you told
me a Philippe up don't you know that our
Charlie Roberts tied for the natural
fudge and I said oh she's gonna say
hello see what's up so I ended up going
to a natural fudge and when I got there
the wife of the owner was making out one
of the cooks keep it going
Barbara right yeah I think so wait do
you mean the husband just died yeah he
died originally died and she was already
in the kitchen yeah yeah that was the
first spot that's where we would go I
wasn't the first
Alonzo Botev yeah well it was Vito keep
telling people that it was a vegan spot
but even though theater
before the craze it was down by the
Scientology building fountain by aunt
and we should go there that was the only
Tuesday night spot and it was literally
like the beatnik vibe and it was 1991
and that's where I saw Andy Dick and he
did like one spot and I remember that
and he was like screw this and the next
thing I know he was on TV
I started at 9:00 you know I know that
night before yeah cuz I would make me
495 like my son was born in 94 93 93
right so I quit and restarted again so I
was offered not a lot back but those
were now with the general time yeah I
remember because you used to ask me like
where to get up and stuff so that's I
had a little bit more seniority believe
that also Brian host but he did the
legend a legend these are all guys well
I haven't seen al for a long time
Wow we ran into Al he pulled up next to
us at a stoplight ya know that's how you
guys met him dose of Big Bertha we do
but I still remember people's old bids
yeah I can wait and the way here I was
thinking about his old bed remember when
we to watch that cartoon of life in
times of Tim oh hell yeah a little black
trans best H come in yeah that was a
voice that was he's the first and they
they changed you out of there or what
wait I was never on eleven times that
was not his voice I keep telling you I
originally did the character first yeah
so we they have a character like that
they have a prostitute who hangs out in
front of his building that he's friends
with
oh yeah Jimmy just say they he'll be
ordering chicken like I was siding with
the way where you live in the hood
mm-hmm and it's trying to be a funny of
ordering I think y'all got chicken wings
[Laughter]
the black truck yeah when I said oh we
running for president like this was I
said we're gonna have our first black
our first transvestite president and
then she don't be like I like to talk
about heads of state Foreign Affair
policy oh yeah I have to get the voice
down it's been a minute do you gotta be
careful we talked about Jesus all right
[Music]
but yeah that was back in the day I used
to do that
well do chores just got very bad no no
no we've been thinking about it for a
while just the time and all that and had
time we don't wanna get all crazy with
getting a whole wedding thing going so
we're gonna do it so we just told her
parents and we decided Friday morning we
just shot out there that way
do you know what her sister her
brother-in-law her brother-in-law
everybody Bob and dad know we just told
Mary and it's funny cuz Marla you don't
want to wait anything well good luck
driving over there you're gonna get
married today you don't want to walk I
thought you're gonna have a party or
somebody just wanna go all right well
you know dress a that morning that
morning yeah Elvis was like 300 bucks
extra all right so I thought was gonna
be cheesy right so I was like now I talk
good would you two normal little [ __ ]
they went to the [ __ ] strip got a
cheap what huh
so we go there right we had our thing in
the head of his
I know uh you know we have a Elvis
impersonator here his name is Tim
so-and-so you won't write you know we
can have it on the house so we just did
it I'm not worth it man but he looked
more like Roy Roy or looking for
discounts thought it was too cheesy but
but then he came there and we did it and
they you know offered it and boom you
just got married
do you take dish I don't know what do
you call these things these days right
dishrag [ __ ] right I'm sorry lady
that's my egg nobody bit Mary [ __ ]
like - married you but had to be up he
has to be PC oh yeah it'll be a stretch
huh how long have you known your lady no
no Brigades almost two years I read your
book by the way pretty shitty yes bro I
didn't buy it by the book Oh your dad no
I really had a lot of stuff I remember I
didn't know that I'm I remember hanging
out late you know which you go eat yeah
and I'm there restaurant that's a
different name now which one way the
back broke we was a health food no it
was more the one that's out named after
a restaurant American Graffiti oh no
before that
yeah
Oh oh yes yes yes dude that's how long
we've been in the game we used to go to
Mel's on sunset before it smells yes I
was in Tel Aviv yeah Brian
yeah pretty sotto yeah Freddy bro yes
dude we should go all the time I
remember when we saw you plannin on a
scary movie
mm-hmm we scream all scream scary
nobody was shot in Mexico by the way and
tonight I said that I was shot in Mexico
so a lot of those people who are driving
you like some Mexicans bro directors
Gilbert su voto we go back and yeah
what's up with the book would you read
in there I read that you were - I'm
logged in - or like in writing class
yeah I did you wrote everybody a letter
all the celebrities yes because your
favorite dude with the gayathri's
company John Ritter yeah yeah yeah wow I
really wrote a little to everybody could
you try to get fun yesterday you fought
each other each other if fun before I
didn't go for a fun just the letters bro
93 and I wrote different famous actors
and see if I could give me like 200
bucks because I was follow my dream and
somebody wrote me back
you're lying I forget who it was but it
was someone William Shatner
somebody did a damn I should have read
my book before I came here we're gonna
quiz me on that but yeah that was um
that was yeah I thought you wrote a lot
of people do John Ritter was one of my
heroes and we didn't really really were
live in your car then yeah yeah when
we're hanging out I didn't look we had
your C over here
really yeah and your C was of telling us
yeah man I was living in my car
that after I'll be the last guy hanging
out the last guy say goodbye hey there
ever you did that - yeah I used to have
a car I was like an old white like
Chevrolet or something and it we had a
nice back seat so I had a futon bed
pillow like you know like the we lay a
little mattress yeah and so I was able
to take that from the front seat and put
it through the back seat and it had like
a big back window so it was enough room
so that kind of became at night my bed
and was great as I had this mobile kind
of home and I was like one night I would
sleep in West Hollywood the next Beverly
Hills
I was mobile baby one time I was
sleeping in Santa Monica but I only did
it for a few months you know on and off
he's a pioneer that - that's all over
yeah I'm getting props for a lot of
things transvestitism
sleeping in your car is are you doing
your dates we could edition on the phone
I did mine too already
[Music]
I'm only part you did acting school in
London yeah so I wonder like comedy no I
see I was talking about this was my
other day so I started as a stand-up and
how do you remember this place called
the LA cabaret yes dig that guy's a
buddy afterwards
well he that was like that was a spot on
the 80s before everybody will yeah yes
so what's cool is now is is are they
coming what's fascinating to me is that
people pay for stage time now which is I
don't understand rigors understand why
we do it yes one thing I don't know
we're very lucky whatever but we got to
perform in front of real people but not
always the time a lot of time there are
comedians but 5:00 to 7:00 every day was
an open mic and after I flirted with it
like he was saying you do a set and then
you don't do a set for four months and
then you do another one you're scared I
was very scared totally and then I went
and I said I got to commit to this so I
would go there every day between 5:00
and 7:00 I would sign up and get the
three minutes and that's how I was like
started as a stand-up but the acting
started coming out people think I acted
before I was standing but no acting came
out of staying there because people
would see me my first agent I got out of
the Laugh Factory because I would wait
every Tuesday every Tuesday and I waited
so many Tuesdays and Jamie Masada slack
but do you hate so much I don't even I
don't know you but you've a here all the
time so he just brought me in because he
saw that I was always there always
waiting and so then I started getting
those like 3-minute spots at like 1 a.m.
that's one comedy when you go up at 1:30
I'd be a crowd which is now it's
happening again but then I started did
all the comedy and then I saw this
program for two months to learn how to
do Shakespeare and I thought I should
just do that because I should have that
skill and that's why I went over there
it was only it was quick but I started
as a comedian that was a long story I'm
sorry do you know what any more dates
impressed that you came back I'm
impressed you came back to the question
oh no I was a little craft no I'm always
about finishing conversations when I get
up in the morning I write down what I
want to talk about because people start
to conversations they never finished
totally i jus do all about that he was
like what are we doing here that guy
from scream 1 & 2 I got a name Rekha I'm
baking back bean buit in my Buick or do
you get paranoid about what you say now
yeah see you can you know why because
you have a box checked
generally I'm saying you're a Latino man
right so you can get away with a little
bit but my crowd could expect this
biggest they know what to expect but
there's some people like the newer
generation but I'm not you know who who
say Latino eggs
well clewd are Latinos Latinos now
brother Latinos hipsters he's got a chip
stirs bro I can't say nothing cuz I'm a
white guy in my 40s and we're in a
timeout
[Laughter]
dude I do jokes about I do characters
like he knows I'm gonna do all these
characters that's how I started in
voices and then I do like a voice now
like I do a black lady voice and then I
comment on the fact that I'm not allowed
to do it and then I do a joke on that
because it's like literally you know
like I did it at the belly room like two
nights ago and I killed I do the improv
a kill but sometimes you get the wrong
crowd and you know people get all like a
college yeah you have to throw in a
qualifier that's what lights you because
yeah that's like I'm not allowed to do
characters because of its weird it's a
bizarre time do you agree yes sir I
don't know if people get offended like
for anything but like like I was I was
hanging out with mobile Rodriguez Oh
more later to talk to anybody
so that Bobo start walking towards me
and I was like playing around like
Michael Scott Toby no so I sat next to
him and we started joking around about
the event and then some girl started
talking then it took political you know
yeah believers love that word right
there triggered ah and powerful
problematic what that's like he's part
of said by Latinos
it's also said by black people about
other black people who might not be as
woke or might be doing something that's
embarrassing it's like okay that this
person is of our group you know it he's
doing something or saying something that
is out of connect can I not politically
can I say something and you tell me from
my future script woke comedy is comedy
it's not funny it's like a TED talk
yeah whoa how many is not comedy our
other day like I was going through my
what happened but there was a woman
talking you know and I don't know sure
okay I'll give you the chance but then
she went to this is this
but then the part where the person I was
about to be in there being on like a
gospel I thought you were saying Church
scripture like and God spoke to the
disciples I say give me grapes but
they're you talking well we don't know
for sure that Julia great xerath she
wasn't beaten Christian but she was
actually given a TED Talks like a thing
but everything was people laughing at
her little joke store never do that
well comedy put Jewish you're right it
was well-covered no comedy is supposed
to make you offended to the point where
you that's you're not supposed to laugh
and that's why you laugh I do it I do
this all the time I say comedy club is
our safe space right it's not this is
crazy like there was a big show and I
was just want to do like host a place
but then when I got there you know host
you know can do five minutes but just
10-15 minutes in between
alright that's cool first event then
turn into a five minutes then just go up
there one time so I went up there one
time I did my obits then some some girl
got offended okay there was a guy it was
like I get the crowd going
there's a white there was a sea of
Mexicans bro first of all there could be
some adore and it could be Cuban
Peruvian you know but I am gonna
anthropology as you know there were
three there were all Mexicans bro they
were all Mexican bro you know I don't
work for ancestry.com you know yes we
don't have time to get a pass out you
know cotton swab for everybody yeah for
me a little C in the bro in the back a
cockfight bro but the one white gang of
front bro looking creepy as [ __ ] right
and I say marry somebody check this guy
for a pistol a gun and they K right
there's some girl said some girl got
offended for him we all could become one
first of all Beach how you gonna be one
when it's all baskets yeah I could count
how many black me with her made a
reference to like shooting up the place
or something like that which is a
stereotype but then I do try to do a
joke stereotypes exist for a reason
reality well no it's like I do this
character I do I carry good gay
character and I'm like jeez it's Christ
and then I do the whole thing of like
I'm now somebody said to me you know not
all
gay guys talk like that now go you're
correct but a lot do I mean Nami the way
that that guy came up to you like like
both gay guys the most I guess was
there's like a male/female the the one
doesn't like to dominate one speaks like
that you know we don't know how to bear
it'll come your beer the top someone
call me a beer no hey guys Oh times hey
guys gay guys love me trans love me they
all come to the show love me Mexican
people love me it's white people that
are annoying because they are the ones
like cuz because you know what it is bro
it goes deep they didn't grow up in the
city okay
he grew up in the city I grew up in the
city I took the subway I met everybody
so I didn't grow up where I was just
right white people I grew up on
everybody else
so so they don't know they're like my
supposed to do this do you agree with
that theory yeah well it seems like the
latnok skids are acting like you know to
turn white later I was I would say like
without my Latinos that the whole world
will clap even females but now for reals
right like even when I save all my
Latinos that they know that I'm telling
more Latina women and Latino men but now
these new Latinos are saying Latino
latina X to include everybody right
because in the Spanish language you have
masculine and feminine words and so
Latino would apply to a man latina would
apply to a woman but if there's a group
of yeah even all women and just one guy
the word becomes Latinos you know that's
what they don't like at the GE
experience whoo white people
experimenting excrement Thank You Philip
Frederic people white people would have
benefited at this
real bad right now especially libros
when Jamie Kennedy had that episode
where he got a bunch of homeless people
and brought him over no he went to Home
Depot and I got a bunch of Mexicans and
they [ __ ] about him or we're broke
not to work to be part of the bore his
birthday party yeah that was a sweet one
it was all Mexican dudes that I got a
Home Depot I paid them to be my friend
hundred percent and they were like it
was fun but it's people will get
offended by that no like so that was I
don't mind the friend
I don't mind offending people I don't
care I that oh yeah I just hate that
like if you say the wrong thing you
[ __ ] ain't right they're pulling
dudes out yeah they're yanking people
out of the [ __ ] wood man
sometimes it's out of context too though
what they say and what they oh [ __ ] so
it's like a funny words it's gonna come
like honestly bro you watch we're gonna
ban together we'll all comedians are in
a band together because even though
there's all types of different comedians
like there's some that may you know
within the community feel certain work
or not work that we're all gonna have to
and I think it's happening because it's
we want that free speech and it's people
are going cuckoo you know what we're
just gonna start charging more money to
get the ending writers review your show
and quote jokes
I hate Russell people come oh right
about it on the blah on their blog oh
yeah
we deny all press requests that was
another study tour I never get those
requests
when I was at Last Comic Standing I was
at the last harvest and enjoyed it was a
woman in the front and she was shattered
her notebook
[Laughter]
Home Depot that's right bro wait so when
you're on Last Comic Standing what
happened
those are late enough Rob bro reviewing
the whole show uh-huh
and then at the end then I'm Tommy John
again started bagging on her anything
else but the next day she stared dating
some bastard I bought him we know he he
was on too long horrible but she was a
mine though wait so take me through
after you what was your first pop out
was it Last Comic Standing you were
doing other stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah I
wasn't sure I would know when somebody
was on not fluffy house no I was like a
guest judge one time where fluffy was on
not when you were on though yeah show
has helped so many people now after you
won that where you just beyond touring
beyond we went to 85 city tour
immediately after those badass some of
these theaters better part never go
again no which was ups which was the one
in Colorado in the middle of the [ __ ]
slow it was called our Vice
the Vail Colorado but now it's vice
Colorado pretty much it very Ocala Home
Depot Colorado why I'm looking at the
camera you guys are looking there okay
what's a full of zero tourist crackers
laughter we'll tell me worried about
Elvis bro how do you do it bro hey
doesn't matter if I vote God in there to
you are you guys good with God or should
I not and about God I'll go for it about
God I'll thank you very much for a cool
chair
all right guys got rings oh you don't
got no rings huh you guys want to buy
some rings I'm on ah dude we're gonna
pick up our ring they're on layaway no
but uh he's all right cool Oh mr.
Rodrigo okay let me do this in my head
real quick Rodrigo all right cool oh
yeah let's do it
cool just real quick it was super quick
while he was yeah had the rings and
everything and I guess that he told us
about this place called the pepper mill
where everybody goes for breakfast a
local place so he's all yeah man you
guys gotta go there but he was like a
pitchman I guess he gets a 10 bucks per
person yeah he's almost real cheap man
but it was not anyways it was real good
but yeah so he was cool quick and all
wearing all dark I don't know man it
looked like he had a wig but I think
they said he had a wig like Randy Quaid
yeah gave him alone ah [ __ ] no do you
know what [ __ ] that for the body slimy
who's like built like the honky Tonk Man
[Laughter]
let's go so you did it there yeah right
there
and now live with your girl yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah well you know during the
week we stay there and then during the
weekend was there I was warming her how
their parents yeah in a Brea
but there's two houses so you throw your
underwear further dad my robe roof right
now
the robot knows but it's funny though
because I had a friend that my buddy in
the DA's office I'll do the probe you
can't people even my my listen if I
didn't have a house tour to go then that
would probably be an issue but you know
like some people feel locked down and
somebody's roof yeah that's how it's
been going on a bigger house yeah yeah
your bathroom has to be waiting for the
data Kamala shared folder that I
wouldn't allow it manager I like to walk
around like a [ __ ] wrestler Brooke
I know it's hi yeah well that's how
y'all used to because he was like he
used to do it but he doesn't do the joke
anymore would he'd be like homeboy from
blood in blood out dude like what he's
always gonna be something going down as
old he's old you finally did it one time
at the tortillas and a [ __ ] destroyed
it what he's always been he would walk
around with this when we're at me Ivan
Vinnie he'd be in his indoors all right
I'll be right I'm gonna take a shower
dog on the phone let it happen you were
walking around with your underwears like
sorry Piper was a very good where's
tortillas I remember well Kody's done no
that's it Montebello do it I think I
remember Danny and poplar yeah bro cross
the street from the Beverly Hospital to
close your first time I saw your ban on
anything you were at some MTV van
commercial yeah dude that's broke me
robust are you and then whatever with
all hi no that are high but you were
around me I thought you were the guy
from the guy from Beck back down no that
would be back because I thought you were
the guy from the guy back
you know exact I was back yes dude that
came from comedy of comedian who I can't
remember right now but it's in my book
god five of us an audition for a test
spot for El Pollo Loco the crazy chicken
I think chubby comedian huh that chubby
comedian he should doing a bed card I'm
jealous funny brought by down hit a
bitter but he was not she was chubby he
goes yeah you ever heard of James Dean
in that movie
oh-oh-oh Eric Edwards yeah yeah yeah he
was one of the he was the first guy on
the circuit to really blow up
yeah he was in problem child he was in a
lot of stuff but then somebody got us an
audition and then from that I didn't get
they'll play logo but then I got the
Vance then there wasn't led to another
man so it was yeah the dude the van's
was like paid my I was like that I went
from zero and to like having like six
thousand dollars which is the Cadillac
though hey brother we used to go do that
uh the potluck with big fat chewy at the
Comedy Store
oh yeah let's put everybody neighbors
old [ __ ] joy yeah how Bell is that
dude dude Iron Man that soap opera right
what you would have to write your name
bro and you make sure they would leave
peel it off they don't rip your name off
bro wait it's chewy witness anymore no
he's still alive yeah it's just not at
the common he's not at the store dude
shoe he was cool yeah chewy used to take
our little thing and be like that's why
I try to be homies with him because he
would like you're right half your name
of they go Jamie can Adar and if they
say it wrong you're like it's me Kennedy
like no butts Kennedy are like you got a
dude that's so funny because you know
they will put your name on the pot look
like that bro and then you try to make
your name rice they will rip it half
your name off dude
I remember and it would be old-school I
heard both seniors more probably packed
now but I remember I would go up I swear
I would go up one later I think
like to it was still am I crazy to get
the story used to go till 4:00 a.m. yeah
suddenly was part look like it would be
with shopping it was a potluck with a
bunch of little fools going like a young
comment going up but then all the
regular Google yeah yeah get the good
type of eight to ten thirty
yeah the potluck will continue after
that well did you back at would yeah and
then and then but people would come in
regulars and do like 20 minutes and
destroy and then they would Ben I
remember I had his shirt it was like a
me bazan I remember the early 90s like
look like Paisley's and went up and
there go give it up for Vanilla Ice's I
can't say the word brother
nothing special needs brother they would
you were like I say at the potluck at
this somebody went up and they're like
four hours I remember one time I follow
James and Stephen to the third he just
like an hour and a half but night to go
up and do three minutes I got a minute
and a half they just got rid of it oh
yeah he was incredible people don't know
bro somebody bumps duty to come back
there two three minutes three minutes
bro I met my first time I ever got
bumped was at the Laugh Factory by
Rodney Dangerfield hey you know I was I
know is that incredible because I
thought I hate feel bad when I bump
people but I tell them that story
because I was auditioning for Comedy
Central for like premium blend that he
came in he did
just SROI blaze the room you know and
then I just had to go up no one knows me
as well but there's a good one to get
Bob yeah [ __ ] yeah that's tight that is
crazy I was a comedy contest that was
tell my friends that I'm that I want
only because all my first show there for
the projects then without Caputo dude
Acapulco wasn't bad our Hollywood yeah
Tony Roma's at Universal City paid 50
bucks and a meal at least it
negotiate remember Dave Garrett is the
lawyer and he would negotiate like an
extra side he's in law school
it was also comedian little sidebar here
he's like you know you got a sweet
potato like he wants the creamed spinach
to throw that it like literally would
negotiate but those were like dude those
are the gigs man baby bucks
and food my wife and I got married we
stood at this hotel when he made was to
the hotel we're now betting peaches no
Marina del Rey and I'm walking and I
look to the left that's all my wife you
know what I think they stand-up comedy
here cause they're cows and was this
yeah house upstairs right wrong is dope
cows a nice yeah dude we did time it was
good see people back in that day that
was coffee houses so imagine in New York
coffee house what comedy was like got
hip in the 60s that's what LA started
have but they didn't have Starbucks
right there was no Starbucks yeah stuff
so we would do it it was either the
store the fact of the Improv which is
very possible to get in it probably
harder hard
everything was so hard so you had all
these coffee houses and then they had a
circuit and that got good and that we
were starting to get known on that yeah
but then it was like then agent started
coming out to there and then bring us to
the big clubs but we had to create that
yesterday your name and then after a
wild man if you if your friend were in
the room you go up first even though
your last yeah yeah it was totally a
different time so it what happened bro
you got married not married live our
Barry no I've never been married how
many how many times you've been married
was once is your first time yeah
I honestly do know the reason I've never
been married yet
is cuz I was driving over here thinking
about this cuz I I don't want to have
divorces
right so my parents were married for the
60 years 60
that's insane yeah and if you talk like
dr. drew he'll say like you don't want
to live up to that because that's an
incredible expectation now they probably
should have been divorced a lot a lot
but
how about one right over 40 head a bit
up by his father yeah okay here Oh Jamie
now my dad used to go like this this was
my sex talk my dad would say hey Dre he
was from the south he saw my father
going length when he say miss movin my
first busy go you go out that little
girl laughs nah boy
well she's cute little girl is she gives
you uh I was my sex talk you used sounds
you know she had nice uh you know he
would never use bad words or as far yeah
exactly so uh because I thought I would
be divorced because I was traveling I
was you know going the different places
that was a little bit of a ho so and I
just started yeah what do you mean for
reals yeah me we're on a different movie
set are you're on a different city doing
comedy I mean yeah so you start
[Laughter]
he's meaning a flash knife are we
getting in trouble given her that aren't
you paranoid I'm you give her that pink
steel there Jamie open up for the Lumbee
slap actually you're performing there
when I went outside your girlfriend what
are your merch yes
no he get the gay bit lighter they get
any better than this
like the late for sm will be where I saw
you know what he made it he yeah
you will tell that story about how many
times over when I was hurt
yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ] boring way
which was the story about when you were
talking to her and John Mayer came over
spanked oh yeah but I was trying to like
hook up with her multiple times and
[Music]
Backstreet Boy like scooped it up so I
was always getting black she was very
sweet and she saw the very sweet for
somebody who's so well known to be
sitting there
hey look it I would be that I would say
what's needed Felipe so by merged I mean
anybody sells merged sweet before
someone like her but she really did
she'd beg a saloon she produces some of
my DVDs and it was extra you know so but
you know eventually she got tired of
that she was never in Malibu finest
[Music]
people pushed me to get out of the PP
out of the way it's gonna take a vision
with her anything
I'm even been back and I go to my
website wow dude I remember that real
life yeah that's like a Rob Rob Diggle
Rob Riggle Rob Reider funniest bit he
something about everything I don't know
I'm a kid [ __ ] I love but
you gotta listen to hear the bit about
him like in his neighbor and doing
push-ups every time she passes by or
every time you pass by he'll turn making
a [ __ ] swoosh art and sick little
jump and then his neighbor his homie
knew that he liked her
so what they brought a you like to
brother school I know she's that right
now so he took it to a room and I feel
older brother [ __ ] the [ __ ] Dipper
comedy works when I heard that I won
last Comic Standing brought you the
headline a theater I don't give a [ __ ] I
scream Brooke have to keep little rules
I was a hurry because all that go you
know what my real life back then at that
moment that met let her know learn the
push-ups or enough you know bang shots
wait till our he liked the girl so try
to impress her in the sweetest way and
then the guy over and let him peek in
the room with some dudes brother his
older brothers just tearing it out which
brother was doing I don't know little
brother
yeah that is [ __ ] up that is the human
condition in a nutshell that was way
more intense I was talking about the
other day there are so many dicks around
this world you know we were talking
about stuff like that like somebody just
yeah just breaking your stuff and I said
that's human nature that is the problem
I'm eating my [ __ ] soluble
[Laughter]
[Music]
Carlos I roll with that meet the it's
harder right torrid order what happened
I don't know
us the Riggle story no you didn't know
that you were talking about dick
oh my carne asada bull rolling or chata
and I still fixed one as you go but a
roll here so there's a fixie bike with
no seat and one of the child is beat the
[ __ ] up bro
like if somebody hit it with a
sledgehammer and like you know you have
to do all that if you just stole the
[ __ ] bike but he just did it to be a
dick yeah she said Lisa said those are
humans you're right because Allah would
never go over to where the beaver lives
and take a [ __ ] in his house he
alligator eggs that's holy just tubular
there's somebody I wasn't a dick like
that I did what okay bro a bunch of guys
playing handball they're playing
handball and they're a bunch of cholos
they like they had like a case of beer
and my brother and I we took it we here
today that's your brother
he will do it
Jamie carried in the house bro yeah you
got dates coming up - Tori yeah I got
some tonight I'm leaving I'm going to
Schaumburg Schomburg people improv I'll
be there this weekend and then in two
weeks I'm doing side splitters in Tampa
I don't know no STK was there last week
yeah he was Louie was there which which
is either one of two things either but
it's awesome that you know that it's a
great club yeah we went in there three
days imagine now brother
there'll be a funny sketch I like Louie
Louie came back and you're looking for a
new agent and then you have all he teeny
when he walks in there's like plastic
everywhere like they're gonna kill
somebody who is Middleton black beauty
okay he wrote up on grab a book about
Katt Williams about his days of opening
up for him he would say that I've been
writing for good
wait how does cat feel about the book
well there's a comment well there's a
story at the end about you show up to
cats how capsule shop that's house and
the room is cat with two bodyguards and
the whole room is filled with plastic
and there's like several baseball bats
and he thought he was he has to pull the
key to the car they can't will have
lured him yeah he asked for the keys to
his car and I think he gave him the keys
and then he said he had to go do
something have one of the keys yeah yeah
and I think somehow he got out of there
I can t remember how he go
I've read that book but yeah yeah the
military of that book he's not worried
[Laughter]
were you write about plastic in back
I think it's been probably four or five
years yo man Katt Williams genius
there's Sabra we don't we do hats huh
that was him yeah he do a little trench
coat and a hat yeah look at it the
Hamburglar Wacka Wacka it's crazy how
many you never partied hard like
everybody else
you mean like drugs yeah weed a little
bit of weed sometimes but I'm not you
know OG louis xiii yeah i mean cuz dude
I got a I get paranoid you know so it's
like I'll get period or sober role
really I you've lifted right now but I
just I can't I wouldn't be able to think
if I go three hours sober the morning
I'm gonna have like 30 enemies by in
Twitter is the grab yeah snapchat yeah
we'll just tell people how many people
have it waste out a [ __ ]
anybody want to buy that [ __ ] lose your
Bob you know you got no [ __ ] follow
you got no [ __ ] we were say they take
you to all my followers and how am i
supporting you know supporters I'm
nobody
so there's you want to go awfully big
with you rescuing no pimples
no no like some people were just like
not boo but just they go up there man
and like I I throw the biggest creep
sometimes when I go to somebody's page
and I look and then I realize I'm the
only one there that was hot that was
awkward you know he was gonna live video
with somebody like do the only one bear
oh that's creepy no just you and then
are you saying so like if we were on
here right now we would just be with
Joaquin Rodriguez Wow so you want to
talk about DJ's who are big seed and I'm
the only one listen you bro
I see and I'm like I write I write down
like so if I'm the only working I make a
request so how many have you Rachel
written ah partly wrote Malibu's Most
Wanted about our movie
thank you preach I partly why didn't
write it but I don't know better
Jamie I don't know got the Laugh Factory
boot outside of the bootleg for real
girls that go yeah downtown are late
that would pop was everywhere bro thank
you you know what we were not there man
why I'm gonna impound
that's your bootleg this deal it was up
there like we're so pleased why yeah
it's too bad way so claim was everywhere
uh kickin it old-school I produced your
show my show I wrote introduced with
help obviously so yeah a few things
produce some stuff no you know it's
different I'm trying to like do it again
but I feel like the more of decision
makers than ever there's never been more
places to distribute content and more
people going like this
what's the characters it's like
overthink everything dot-com and they
want you to do something that's already
done you know we were pitching a reality
show
it wasn't reality it was unscripted this
is the one at the border anyway but we
were pitching it everywhere and every
executive had the same comment well
what's the like goal is there like a
challenge we can do in each episode and
it's like [ __ ] oh my god
do not do it don't do it do not give in
explore the towns around the border and
all that stuff anyway you're gonna pitch
to people that are only getting 10,000
views anyway stay here I'm telling you
it's beyond annoying like I can't listen
to people that were in grade school give
me notes when I was already starring and
screamed too then I dream one scream too
afraid to take a risk on anything new
and different that's because and they
want to they're afraid to lose their
jobs and I say this thing that I say and
you guys can use this on the podcast no
problem I this town has so many issues
it's because we have risk takers
pitching to the risk-averse
right we only live by our balls we got
nothing living in cars you know a young
baby we started nothing these people go
to college don't want to lose their job
it's [ __ ] up they don't match that's
an enormous point hash deep man little
boy when I saw you come in it oh she was
dedicated in the movie Oh she'll be
robbing that guy as good as it gets
yeah so you shot it out of the movie
theaters yeah
you think it was a [ __ ] Club yeah I
was robbing that guy I originally took
that part from Mexican that's a joke
everybody that was we will get off
anyway you know what why people always
taking jobs how about the white people
that give jobs yeah
thank you for the shout out Jamie
Kennedy Sergio Torres yeah man yeah man
so I don't know it is crazy though right
yeah it's like a great time to be your
own entity now it's just a matter of
getting people to see it but like
pitching is like like to me I would
think it would be a no-brainer six years
ago he had a manager I mean I've been as
manager for the last six seven years but
six years ago he was somebody he was
with somebody else and that person that
company that company and one of those
pitches was about a couple of guys kind
of like clerks you know but who worked
in a weed shop you know Kohner guys wait
a minute I don't see that at all go
ahead
but wait six years ago okay and he that
manager goes yeah I don't know I don't
think people are really ready for a weed
show yet and we're like look it's it's
legal in these states it's medically
legal in these states and like it's
grown the four sizes managers out the
door and we were just like and then he
started calling with some conference
call about how he could get up the
Twitter followers oh my god and I was
like we got in this relationship
wow you're not gonna shut the company
out don't shout it out well he was with
roar but it was small it was a guy how
many shows came out a tweet after that
thank you for years later actually my
weed and they'll tell you know what this
is really too many show
comedians there's another one pops up at
HB I know I know that's the biggest
thing when you're pitching a sitcom well
what do you want him to do because you
know for a job because you know we want
to avoid comedian because peon says
don't really like that Seinfeld was a
popular show about a comedian or
crashing is in its third season right
now on HBO yeah
the Margo lady give Margo many shells me
that one kills me and it's like yeah but
you haven't first of all you haven't
seen a Latino perspective as it come
there was a whole different community of
people imagine garnish and no company so
shows it a big mustache yeah he plays
like a 7d it's like Freddie Prinze style
guy you know I think but it's you can't
get past him the whole show cause we
play [ __ ] natural Thursdays know who
get a Dodger Stadium we wanted we wanted
to do a comic who had fallen but I mean
that's funny somebody's there Matt Blake
question my question morning no wasn't
that Blake he's that I roared how do you
even know you were mentioning us about
somebody special once thought would
people find you well what's your
Instagram go to Instagram at Jamie
Kennedy no judge Jamie McCanney
Instagram Jamie Kennedy on Twitter Jamie
Kennedy on Facebook I don't know snap
you can find me on there
any of this [ __ ] we got a 2-man
everything is you are seeing then once
yeah I was was a little comedian Jenna
Jenna Janey or Jenna something Jenna
goes jelly start hope you using the
Beverly Center once I like dude I don't
remember I'm going on seeing in a few
times I forget the first time though
with a female comedian no you sure
[Laughter]
you're still cool bro have a Wikipedia I
do but I don't we did it I don't know
people wait you ready thanks T
fact-checked how do you everybody shits
on it but it's pretty accurate some of
my baby
your stuff is published on your all they
do is basically they go back at my site
though yeah used to be totally wild in
his biography is crazier than that stuff
will movies that I never did on IMDB
that's cuz people tell you because they
want to hype up whatever project they're
doing and they think they can tag you
but you can't quit you can't tag like
ABC I was on an ABC show or anything
that'll good just the artist booted but
people can tag artists he's tagged on
like two or three things but I some of
it is real
yeah yeah it's not enough it's weird it
totally it's spotty
there are people that have like these
these huge Wikipedia's and it's like I
had never heard of you and you know
they're in there like writing I've never
put one thing in second dan he crossed
the street what happened was he was
inspired by Paris and it's like what are
you because I'm too busy you know I
barely have anything you will never
approve this photo no you can arm
wrestlers you'll bring a murderer in
Modesto this is three things I'm gonna
tell you it go that's after we I was a
boy I had off you like Roy Bob left a
bottle this was in San Diego during
comic-con in 2009 I had a bottle of
Prosecco the night before and I was in I
was dating Jay love and we just got an
argument a hundred percent fax that's
for a Wikipedia I wouldn't improve the
red carpet with somebody yeah I know
that's uncomfortable because she's
famous but no one ever asked me to photo
who you have but like what about the
girl from Chili's I dated she wanted to
be an actor
cher to bloom in any have you was born
he was born an Upper Darby Township yeah
is that right by mister where I'm wigs
over there right by my lord there were
power wigs over they go to court
Lord Kennedy why did you have your dates
why did you write your dates this is so
weird you wrote all your dates
you shot my [ __ ] out too no bro I got
Schomburg this one
I got Thursday through Sunday yeah dude
I must be kill annoying
oh they added some in Tampa Louie CK new
paper Club at splitters I don't know I'm
actually most toward the end in my tour
I just shot a special so everybody
looked for I'm I gotta finish the Edit
today actually
look I said right there Jamie Kennedy
wife what are you putting in the next
days Jamie kids Network Jamie Kennedy I
went I don't know yet I got it I made it
independently and there was a guy that
wanted to produce it that produced his
and and I was almost our boat oil
because I right now everyone I talked to
you did it independently yeah and some
of the biggest specials you see now are
independent
except Netflix just said they're not
sure how they're gonna deal with that
but but you know what and I'm and I
guess what and I was like but I was like
oh [ __ ] but then I literally went on
Netflix and some of the biggest specials
on there are like deep like underneath
like houses with bad garages like
there's so deep and they're still huge
so it's just about being there but if I
could do it anywhere people are putting
stuff on Vimeo and it's killer I know
yeah that we did it on we did it
independently and we spent way less than
oh yeah anybody you know they need you
you know and it looked beautiful and
that guy Claud if I don't know if you
were ever gonna consider working with
him but they did a good job alright so
so so raw realistic a real media unreal
media is the company yeah here's some
trivia Jimmy Kennedy brought in divorce
Christ he was considered to play Bob
sugar and Jerry Maguire yeah really
no I auditioned a lot and then Jay got
it I said that story the other night the
comments what I bought Jalen Howie that
was his first big breakout movie I
auditioned I mean in March you're also
coming to comics and mohit oh yeah
yo you gotta go there because you know
why because you're funny and you're
legend anyway but just in case it's
Native Americans you are anyway children
are you that's a dude wait you want to
hear my voice yeah my lady do cuz it
came this lady that I used to work at
the supermarket you would ask for
samples lunch me and now I do character
it gets quiet sometimes so this is what
I say wait isn't this the age of
acceptance right like nobody feels like
they are right like men feel like the
women dogs feel like their cats don't
let's feel like their croissants
doughnuts and croissants have gotten
together
what if inside I feel like a black woman
would be accepted if I was walking
around uh y'all want to go to Starbucks
what if I felt like that was me I
wouldn't get accepted but you're
supposed to get us at community if you
actually are part of the community and
that's where it comes from where where
this is part of your environment
black people accept you they will think
that's funny
yes it's white it's white because
they're not comfortable talking about
race stay with me on this one I just had
your hand like Jennifer Love humid most
annoying DVD the most annoying hecklers
of all time
hey stay with me on this or what I white
women 40s
I call them dancing mom I call them
white wine warriors the triple dubs
right am i right
they got that W in them and they're like
I was helping I was helping the show I'm
a bigger fan I brought wanted people to
see you it's a birthday way to speak to
the manager
oh my Ryan stop me when I think every
comic alive would say that they are the
most entitled we got to do a bit about
it whoever they're the most entitled of
anyone like white guys are piece of [ __ ]
what about white women and there's the
oldest [ __ ] on the bachelorette party -
oh this is getting married in two weeks
I had it's [ __ ] chick this is 20 19
maybe 20 18 in [ __ ] penis was it
white privilege Oh looks magazine
hilarious
thank you I take that white privilege
this [ __ ] chick put the [ __ ]
cocktail penis you know the big dick at
the big penis right no one's about that
side
stubby [ __ ] that [ __ ] in my
mouth Oh
[Applause]
but guess I'm the victim battery but
guess what I was at the merch table so I
was like cash of any mo I gotta move the
[ __ ] I don't want to carry comic whose
line privilege yes it was Bill burr who
said that girl came by the other female
comic or whatever it was a female comic
or just another female celebrity yeah
anyway she flicked him in his dick and
he was like like that's a sexual assault
this was one of the things he told if
the writers guild show you this by the
way not only that and to him but also
it's the most painful yeah she flicked
them and like did she didn't know him
and he's like no but you know stuff that
women get away with it go over there and
flick some Aegina see do happen I had
two Terrier dog I had a lady recently at
one of my favorite clubs they're saying
Jose I seen the best right this older
lady I called it a slim jim you know
when they're like 80 in their tan they
never wear I look like a slim jim she
had these red nails and I'm like and I'm
looking at her nails and she goes you
like that red nail but I was like smoker
and I'm like yeah she goes wouldn't that
look good wrap him around your [ __ ] I'm
not kidding 80 years old right that's
what she said to me and I was like I
kind of put him in I'm like me cuz it
was like the second show oh you know you
that that toast to your place is closed
oh the club across the street yeah so
nothing was open so yeah you know bag I
thought you better corporate 52 right I
have do they get us hey guys thank you a
ham roll oh I don't know who booked me
wait we should play a pizza place is Bob
by the way let's go back home anymore
I'm still out there you probably said I
did how many shows you Joe I did like
four well I did before but three years
one night you could probably do 20 man
but a man you got a run from openers
over there Oh big fat happy Luna going
you around yeah crazy I just I did a bad
bro that's what Kristi Salinas from
right I said I got so drunk I'll hop in
the Selena statue they got me for
statutory rape
bbbbb they had concrete evidence people
hey hey what's up yo I got a bound all
right bro you my dates
we're not leaving from yeah hang out
give my dates well so poor will be a
Birmingham Alabama February 15 at the
stardome to the 17 Raleigh North
Carolina it's an all new the whole new
brand new improv February 22nd through
the 24th Miami Florida woods brand new
improv March 8 through 10 tall like a
red I'm coming over for some coffee by
the rising beans
that's Cubano yeah Vaughn oh I have a
good time now so Angelo Texas I'm back
San Angelo looks like New Orleans with
masculinity March 15 I'll be there at
the Performing Arts Center San Angelo
Performing Arts Center also Wichita
Kansas I'm coming to you March 16 Grand
Junction Colorado
Arlington theatre and okay Dallas Texas
injunction is Avalon theater Avalon
theater also Arlington you've robbed in
Dallas before at the end of March orgy
go you coming right you are work we'll
do what you got at the stardome this
weekend yeah Jimmy Kimmel be a big dog
preciate you Congrats